Take a look at this
split screen for a moment.
Trump first appearing before the
as a criminal defendant. Right.
And then later as the leading
Republican presidential candidat
for 2024 on the right.
That's a safe space
that's Mar a Lago
where he railed against the charges
as we said attacked
the judge the judge
his family attacked
the district attorney is prosecuting him
So let's
bring in CNN political analyst
and New York Times
senior political correspondent
Maggie Haberman.
It was
it was great to follow your twee
in real time last night.
As as a former president was spe
I thought it was so interesting
that you said
this is the most united
we've seen Republicans around Tr
since prior to January 6th.
In the insurrection.
Yeah. I mean, I'll give you an e
The New York Post
front page this morning,
The New York Post has been
attacking Donald Trump since the
and today
they chose
they choose Donald Trump over
Alvin Brash. Right.
And so I think you're going
to see a lot of that
because so much of our politics
is about who
you are against versus what you
Now, is this sustainable?
If Trump gets indicted elsewhere
which he might, he's
facing an investigation in Georg
is facing to Justice
Department investigations
we expect some resolution
on all three of those
in the coming months.
I don't know that
that much freight is sustainable
But for right now, Trump's
folks are assuming
that they can point
to this
first indictment and say, see,
this means all of the rest of
these are all political.
And you saw Trump
do that in his speech last night
Yeah, you did. You did as well.
The question
about the gag order,
I think is fascinating.
Are you in Caitlyn?
No.
Trump better than anyone else in
this room.
Certainly Does he keep
challenging the judge here
saying try to silence me,
try to silence me, try to silenc
I don't. Yes, yes.
But I don't think that's
the only thing that he's doing.
I think he is trying to get the
to recuse himself.
I think that is part of
what Trump's game here is,
because he attacked the judge in
using himself
as saying
the judge has too many conflicts
and therefore there's going to b
That is what this is about in pa
Now, it's also a part about the
doesn't believe systems.
I don't apply to him
and he's going to push them
as far as he can.
But just based on conversations
I had with a bunch of people las
after we saw that speech
and after we finished our last t
experience, Caitlin and last nig
our lasting allies together expe
the people that I spoke
to made very clear
that this is where this is heade
that basically remember,
this judge oversaw
a Trump Organization
trial, is overseeing Steve Banno
related to Alan Weisselberg's se
So Trump is trying to change the
which is one of the things
we've seen Trump
do in other cases over time.
And guess what?
The Trump Organization
trial had
business falsification charges i
so you can't ignore that.
We did
learn some new information, thou
in this indictment and statement
about David Pecker,
who was the brand,
the company
that publishes The National Enqu
being invited to the White House
to be thanked
for his help
to Trump during the campaign.
That was news to me
and that and everything that I r
You know,
there were a couple of things as
reading the statement of fact
that goes along with this indict
And Paul is absolutely right in
making the point that it's not c
exactly what the other
the underlying crime
that this relates to is.
But when you read that statement
there were so many things that h
that we had forgotten about.
I had forgotten that am I?
The National Enquirer paid
a doorman
who had made what turned out
to be a false allegation against
But buried in there
is this fact that David Pecker
went to the White House and Trum
thanked him for his help
during the campaign.
It was a reminder
that this case, you know,
there's been a lot of focus on
Michael Cohen,
who is clearly the key witness
and brought the bulk of,
I suspect, documents, texts test
But there are other pieces that
what Michael Cohen is saying.
And I think that David Pecker
testimony, remember,
he was the first witness
this grand jury heard from.
He was one of the last witnesses
they heard from. They brought hi
I think he will be really key as
Fascinating.
Thank you very much, Maggie.
We appreciate it.